what's up people this is your boy Jay
Willer Laos faita in Spanish uh check
out my cool podcast in the boot Lake Kev
podcast bootle cev podcast bootle cev
show special guest in here Superstar Jay
wheeler is here good to see you brother
good to see you too bro how you doing
man very good I mean a little bit tired
because like the time zone here is way
different from to the east coast yeah so
I am a little bit tired but yeah I'm
happy EX exced with everything that's
happening with this new album and this
new type of music that I'm doing right
now yeah like you were saying you're
doing more kind of like a trap R&B type
of vibe on this album right yeah
something very different because I know
people are not used to like me doing
those Stu I have come out of on songs
that are been like R&B tra but I never
done it like for myself so would you
consider like your style more like like
heartbreak music cuz I my artist Alexis
he's he's a he love I mean he you met
Alexis he's a he speaks Spanish and he's
always like I love Jay [__] because it's
like he talks about heartbreak he talks
about like going through like depression
and going through sad times and [__]
like yeah yeah I consider myself like
that that type of music that's my
favorite music to do right because I
feel like I flow so easily I don't know
probably it's because that I've been
through a lot of stuff in love and and
the fact that I've been singing in my
whole life so that's probably why it's
so easy and obviously in this album I'm
not going to leave out some of those
styles of the songs but but yeah I am
focusing on a little bit of trap and RB
but yes if if you if you guys consider
me like this romantic guy on the on the
music industry and yes yes it's going to
be a little different though yeah this
one's going to be a little bit a little
bit different a little bit different um
who I you told me you have uh you've
already worked with hitmaker before but
you got some hitmaker records on this
new album yeah I got two two songs from
hitmaker I mean working with him was was
fun at at the same time was challenging
because it's not the same thing talking
than singing in English it's very
difficult like the pronunciations are as
you can see I'm not I'm not 100% Perfect
When I'm pronouncing any the worst but
it is it is it was a little bit
challenging but it was crazy and and the
fact that I am singing in English and
being able to like drop the song in one
of my albums is it's a blessing this is
the first time you've done uh like an
English and songs on an album that's
mostly Spanish right uh I think so I
don't know if I dropped the uh an
English song in one of my I and in EP I
did it in an EP I I dropped uh Spanish
and and a English song what like for you
uh growing up in Puerto Rico what was
like uh the American artist that like
you kind of grew up listening to that
maybe helped kind of form some of your
style outside of the Spanish stuff I I
listen to a lot of people like Chris
Brown um Casey and Joe Joe Boy to Men uh
damn a lot there a lot of people Rihanna
Neo I mean remember Neo was like one of
the biggest yeah I mean his pen game's
crazy yeah he's one of the best
songwriters of all time yeah exactly
shout out to um so yeah yeah a lot of
people I listen to a lot of people and
and obviously I don't know how I I mold
myself to like be Jay Willer with
listening to all of them so being
inspired by by them so so yeah but yeah
I listen to a lot of people um how hip
are like like it's crazy to see like uh
like Mexican artists having this huge
wave right now like peso pluma so
huge and it happened like super quick M
like were you hip to like what he had
been had like had going on for a while
cuz it just seems like I just woke up
one day and peso pluma was like the
biggest [__] yeah no I didn't fast I
didn't realize I mean I realized one
song was like the one that
says when when I listened to that song I
was like okay who is this guy that was
the first time I heard him after that it
was over it's I listened to to him like
I mean I I seen him and I listen to him
and I Tik Tok everywhere he's he's
everywhere he's one of the biggest
artists I think right now so I don't
know how it happened I mean is is like
the Mexican stuff hitting in in like a
place like Puerto Rico at all I mean cuz
it's different it's obviously totally
different music I mean we we as artists
have tried to like put it there but yeah
I think I think now because of what pep
pluma and bad bunny is doing with group
of frona I think is the name um yeah I
think Puerto Rico is starting to like
get the flow of the that Myan music but
good songs yeah I feel like Puerto Rican
music like like obviously rayone like
music out of Puerto Rico uh the Dr has
like Mexico's embraced it you know what
I'm saying like if you go to Mexico like
that's what they're playing on on the
boat and [__] exactly so I was just
wondering if like they like Mexican
music had a crossover moment the other
the other direction yet some of the
songs like the biggest songs in Puerto
Rico yeah there're they're they're
they're somewhere that's dope uh you
just so you're recently married yes
which is dope your wife's here she
brought your French Bulldog yeah what's
your French bulldog's name Lilo Lilo I
got two dogs I got Lilo and I got uh New
Finland uh just one of big dog she can't
travel as easy with the giant dog ex now
he's in training right now he's called
Apollo like what are you getting him
trained for just like sitting to be a
service dog oh okay okay so then you can
take them on the plane exactly that's my
whole point yeah you know they sell the
Amazon little best for the dogs that
aren't like I mean it's kind of the the
boot the bootleg way of doing it we we
we we tried it and it didn't work oh it
didn't oh you already tried it yeah we
tried a whole bunch of things so like
get I the fact that she's here is a
surprise because they almost not let us
bring her here she's not a service dog I
mean she's she is now but we don't have
the papers on the well you don't want
her on um you don't want that dog to be
on the bottom of the plane you got to
carry the dog no obviously yeah cuz of
the way I don't want n of dogs no none
of my dogs in you might have to buy a a
seat for the big dog though yeah exactly
I don't I don't mind all right we got to
stop the interview real quick tell you
about our folks at my bookie our
partners at my bookie man listen
football season is approaching it is
pre-season right now I can feel it just
have my first Fantasy Draft it's time to
get this [__] money NFL is here go to
mybookie.ag right now sign up for a new
account use the promo code bootleg right
now when you sign up they're going to
give you that first deposit bonus now my
book is crazy because no matter where
you're at you can go on you get in on
some of that NFL action you can get on
some of that baseball action you can get
in on their Live casino Blackjack
roulette slots whatever you're into it's
going down mybookie.ag all right sign up
right now with that promo code bootleg
they're going to hook you up real nice
first deposit bonus free money to gamble
with bro when you sign up what are we
talking about football season is here
this is literally my favorite time of
the year as a degenerate we must
participate we got to get a little
action in every Sunday on something
maybe a little Thursday night football
action maybe a little pre-season action
who do you think's going to win the
Super Bowl throw a 100 on it [__] it
sign up mybookie.ag use that promo code
bootleg and they're going to get you
hooked up with that first deposit bonus
also want to give a big shout out to our
family at King p man want to give a
shout out to King P they have the um
sugar Shan first of all congratulations
to Phoenix Arizona's own sugar Shan for
just winning that title with UFC they
did a collab with them uh these are the
sugar punch honey orange pre-rolls which
are gas all right now this what's dope
about King pom 100% organic all right
we're talking about no tobacco organic
leaves and what's dope is they have
these tping infused tips that people
just love bro they're called the flavor
tips right you like uh you bust one of
these boys out you know what I'm saying
you fill it with your stuff whatever you
want to smoke some of that flour that
you got from
Harden and then you hit the tip and man
oh I just tasted it right now just
flavor full of Flavor now go to King
pom.com right now use the promo code
bootleg and you're going to get half off
half off whatever's on King pom.com if
you don't know King pom is everywhere go
to your local smoke shop go to your
local 7-Eleven they got King poms
everywhere so many
flavors so many Vibes the grapes are gas
yo King pom.com use the promo code
bootleg
50% off let's get back to the interview
um I know your your wife does music as
well you guys have a song together we do
did you guys meet their music uh I mean
yeah because I I used to be a fan of
what she does she was used to be in a in
a show called lavanda the band and I
used to say I used to see her there all
my like all the time and I I remember I
told my best friend which is here right
now I told him that I was going to marry
that girl but it was a long time ago it
was like
2018 2017 wow and and I didn't never I
mean the time that I said it obviously I
meant it and obviously I wanted it but
we you know when you say that when you
see a beautiful girl I me I said that
about JLo when I was like 13 yeah
exactly uh sorry about I mean shout out
to my wife she's better than JLA of
course you you better fix that yeah
shout out to my wife but yeah I I I used
to say that a lot with my with my best
friends and and all obviously but yeah
and in the it was a DM that I sent her I
I told her like hey U you're super
talented but but I sent the DM when I
was Jay Willer when I when I have my
verification and I knew that she was
going to see it yeah so she sees the DM
yeah she rote me back she was like oh
thank you but nothing happened because
she was in a relation Rel ship I was
like in a [__] up relationship too and
and we were like you know just fans just
we had each other in the in the so you
guys broke up each other's messed up
relationships
no no no no no no no no no no when it
you were you were you guys were each
other's backup plans uh I mean people
people are going to people are seeing it
right now like that because stuff that
happening in the in the social media
that people people are like people don't
know and they think they know because
they heard and whatever but the fact the
the real story is that when I was single
when I had my life like okay I was like
now I don't want nobody in my life
because I don't cuz I went through a
whole bunch of things she was single she
was in the same
mentality and God just put us together
how long were you guys dating before you
uh popped the question oh bro like
months no but I told her like
L than a year less than a year yeah oh
this is oh wow like Jer like eight
months eight months after I'm curious
after you guys start dating does she
bring up the fact that she may or may
not have seen your leaked dick video on
the internet no she she she like did she
already do research on what she was
working with she lied her ass off she
was like no I don't even know what she
talking about and I was like yes you
have yes you have seen it you've seen it
I mean at the at the time I was like you
never seen it and she was like no no no
but I know she saw it she saw it yeah
she's still saying she didn't see it
yeah she's still saying it thing is I
didn't know about it until we went to
dinner and then a guy that was his
friend mentioned something about it and
then he was embarrassed about it and he
told me so this was this before you guys
had hooked up yet yeah I mean so then
she probably goes straight home and it's
like exactly she's like let me see what
this guy's working with cuz if it's
small I'm not giving that's exactly what
happened after that she was like okay
I'm going to marry this guy guy yeah and
then it was over now you guys got a
[__] two dogs exactly yeah look at
that that that moved quickly but yeah no
no uh but yeah no for real like it was
it was a crazy experience because I I I
remember like I said I didn't I didn't
want nobody in my life at that time I
was like I would you know what I'm going
to do I'm I'm just go enjoy the fact
that I'm single and I'm going do
whatever the artists always say that
they do that they've be with a whole
bunch of girls I want to do all of that
and God was like nope I'm GNA send you
like this your crush you thought yeah
yeah wow check you out you manifested it
yes sir good for you and now you're
married yes I am very how was the
wedding I mean I we did a you say how do
you say that in in English shotgun
wedding did you guys no like like the
the paper wedding like oh you guys just
went to the courthouse no no no it was
in my house we did a like a ceremony
okay but it wasn't like a crazy like no
we're going to do the crazy one which is
the one that has my wife stressed out
right now uh in December to oh so you
guys are doing the big big one the big
big one with the whole family in
December 2 in Puerto Rico oh that's big
uh we did like a small ceremony but when
we send when we signed the papers wow in
our house that's Fire Man
congratulations I'm a romantic guy you
know if you would really be the goat if
you could just do the ceremony and get
away with not doing the big wedding I
mean we tried yeah but she would have
that it's impossible no it's impossible
we we need to do a I feel like the big
wedding day is strictly for the woman it
is it's like why can't we just buy a new
house with this mddy she she was yeah
was like ah would you rather have like a
brand new paid off tree wagon or
something exctly she was like oh do you
like this and I'm like baby do you like
it yeah then I like it too don't ask me
whatever you like yeah this is all for
you yeah this all for you all I'm going
to do is just be there because I'm your
husband I going to show up yeah I'll be
there yeah I won't be late hopefully
exactly how was your bachelor party oh
no I don't have no no bachelor party no
I don't like that [__] oh really oh no I
don't like that [__] interesting and and
I I mean they did a like a they did the
they did a little thing for her mhm and
I just play video games so she had a
bachelorette yeah in her house with with
her friends wow and you played video
games video games that's my b game check
you out yes sir I don't like that [__] I
don't know I don't know I'm too jealous
for that [__] how did she get so lucky
to have such a sweet man in her life I
have no idea wow what a catch you are
Jay will thank you got to stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our good Folks at blue baby that's right
shout out to Blue Chu man listen
everyone's always asking me does blue
Sho work of course it works because it
has the same active ingredient as Viagra
and
seis it is Dick season out here bro you
know what I'm saying you got to make
sure that dick is up the par you know
you get on that bluechew and uh you're
going to never like I mean I'm gonna be
honest like you remember when Barry
Bonds hit 70 home runs in a season and
now they're not letting him in the Hall
of Fame like you get off that blue Cho
they're not going to let you in the dick
Hall of Fame cuz it's cheating to be
honest you know what know what I'm
saying so blu.com use the promo code
bootleg when you sign up now this is
what's dope about Blu cuz you want to
know if it works well they're going to
send you a month for free free bluechew
in discrete packaging delivered right to
your door but you have to use the promo
code bootleg blu.com promo code bootleg
everything's online no doctor's office
visits no worrying about [__] having
a weird conversation with some [__]
about your [__] [__] no you [__]
in
blue.com free month online you don't
even have to leave your [__]
apartment you don't have to leave
anywhere you just order it it comes in
the mail and then you know you you just
you know you get to work you get to work
all right so use that promo code bootleg
and get a free month of blue chew also
want to give a big shout out to our good
Folks at odd Sox now this is what's up
about odd Sox I'm about to reach into my
odd Sox bag oh man look Odd Socks they
got all of the [__] sick
licenses recently they locked down
cocacola recently they locked down
[__] Transformers Sabin Power Rangers
we got yooo we got Sour Patch Kids you
know they got their odd Soxs Basics and
I'm telling you the most comfortable
socks in the world in the [__] world
all right and they can all be yours 20%
off 20% off using the promo code bootleg
if you go to oddsocks official.com the
most comfortable socks in the
world and they got draws and these draws
are amazing these are this is this is a
small just so we're clear this is a
small yeah yeah chicks can wear these
you know a lot of chicks like wearing
these booty shorts around the Craven
[__] oddsocks official.com whatever
you're into they got the license WWE
Scarface [__] Breaking Bad whatever
oddo official.com promo code bootleg go
over there get 20% off right now let's
get back to the interview I'm curious in
like uh like American music right like
if somebody who did kind of like the
type of music that you're known for
doing kind of like switched up and did
some like trap hip hop uh with there
might be some like uh negative feedback
or people thinking that like hey you
know this is not what you do like do you
do you are you getting any of that type
of feedback from your fans or from fans
of the fans are fans are complicated
when I say complicated um it takes them
a little bit of time to like accept what
you're doing and the are they go with
the flow like I said when I when I first
dropped PTO PTO was my trap song right
now is like my one of my going crazy
right yeah it's going crazy right now
and people were like I don't know Jay I
miss you I miss the and I that was only
one song and people were like I miss you
after and after that song I I dropped a
whole album with romantic music but with
one song people were like I miss the O J
where's Jay and as soon as I did the
remix and anel and Myers with were in
the remix people were like okay I love
this J songs like already golden Spain I
think or it is I think that's what and
and right now people are like okay I
love this Jay I love the fact that Jay
sing his trap so it takes a it takes a a
little bit of time to like make your
fans accept that you're doing something
new but when you do something new you
have to be careful when you do it and
how you do it because um you need to
like you can't just go out of whatever
it is that you are doing and just do
something new right that's why I'm in
this album I'm dropping like a little
bit of both like I'm doing romantic
songs but in a trap in a R&B trappy type
of beat you know right right right so
and and I'm doing size songs and I'm
doing like sex songs and I'm doing like
songs that's talk about drugs I'm doing
all of it but I am trying to like keep
the Jay Willer the Jay Willer Vibe on
the on the you got to keep those those
day one fans exactly exactly um I was
going to ask you uh as somebody who's
from Puerto Rico I know you're living in
the States now how do you feel about
some of the like uh people who are
moving to Puerto Rico for tax benefits
cuz I saw like I think the Paul Brothers
live there like Logan Paul lives there I
don't know well how do it feel I mean
there's some people that are mad about
it ER cuz I know some people are mad but
then some people are like well it helps
the economy a little kind of sh shed I
have no idea how to feel yeah I I I'm
the one that says that if you're if if
it doesn't like harm people then do
whatever you want want to do the
whatever you think is better for you and
yourself because at the end of the day
like you can try to work for people you
can try to do everything for people but
not every people deserve so if you're
like if you're happy if you doing
something that you think is correct for
your for your I don't know for your
money for your for your you still have
like a main residence in Puerto Rico I
don't my mom my mom does you should have
your address as your mom's address so
the the US taxes a you know they ain't
in your [__] Pockets yeah
at least you live in Florida and there's
no state tax but I'd be like guys I live
in Puerto Rico my mom's address is my
address yeah no I I I I haven't done
that and then you put the Florida house
in your best friend's name yeah yeah I
can do that and then you just you save
money cuz [__] the IRS like really you
know what I mean I mean you're right
when does the album come out uh um
probably we're working and we're doing
our best to drop it in October October
so very soon but I'm dropping singles
though the the first who do you have on
the album right now it's just the the
Pao remix with anoel ran Myers all of
them H I'm trying to G Lu again which is
a trap artist too that he is in Pao the
original but he's going to be I'm trying
to make him in uh one of the Sass songs
that I have okay I'm trying to get a
verse of him and he said yes he already
dropped the the verse but I haven't like
just structure the songs I have a newbie
which is a a new artist from Puerto Rico
and I have a couple of more but I can't
say because I'm surprised okay so
album's coming in October tra sir go
support it uh yo shout out to you and
your wife congratulations thank you so
much much much love and uh and and
prosperity to your marriage amen and the
wedding is coming December 2nd December
2nd one of the most stressful days of my
wife's oh I've been married before it I
mean I am married right now I said like
I not yet you're you're [__] up in
this interview Jesus Christ hopefully my
wife don't watch this no it's a very
stressful you got to get the Caterers
you got to get the food you got to pick
the
flowers uh how much is your wedding
going to
cost couple hundred thousand uh half a
million Jesus Christ yeah almost half a
million what are we doing here I know
just buy a house yeah you could buy like
a team almost half a million it's not B
she said it's not no it's less that how
much 300 three I mean 300,000 oh we had
a budget we're over budget you're over
budget if we're over budget then yeah
it's almost like when I so when I get
over budget on my wedding I just started
to uninvite people that's what we're
doing I was like when they told me okay
look this is how much it's going to cost
cuz you have 200 people coming I was
like all right well what is if I have
100 what if I cut that in half and they
told me I was like all right we're just
going to invite 100 people we're trying
to cut a lot of things but for now like
almost like 300,000
almost four it's like it's like I said
it's like almost a half a million wow
you could buy a lot of uh a lot of lots
of things with that you enjoy it it is a
it's a for me is one of the most
important days of my life in my wife's
life so yeah whatever it takes to make
her happy and make her like the Dream
well the most important day of your life
was the ceremony you had at your house
because now you guys are married exactly
so this is a really cool like also kind
of cool day to like you know give your
wife a drink Dream wedding exactly yes
this is for her this is for her yeah
this is my greatest gift for her you're
so romantic yes sir Jay wheeler the new
album is coming soon hopefully October
trappy trappy yeah appreciate you
pulling up brother thank you thank you
for having me here hey what up man uh
you just watched another episode of the
bootle C podcast brought to you by
Harden baby shout out to the family at
harden don't forget make sure if you're
in Las Vegas you get into that taxi as
soon as you land you get into that Uber
say take me to harden all right they
going to take get you taken care of the
most craziest Premium Selection of
cannabis you'll ever find Under One Roof
it's a vibe in there the butt tenders
they going to take care of you man
listen tell them I sent you they're
going to get you right shout out to the
family at harden in Las Vegas the number
one dispensary in the world all right
and we are so proud to be partners with
them so shout out to harden go follow
them online Hardin Las Vegas and check
out their website Hardin vegas.com get
you some swag you know you can't buy
this but you know yeah shout out to
harden